[Music]
this is the sound of hunger
[Music]
newly-arrived Ranga refugees mostly
women with babies or young children many
have seen their husbands slaughtered and
Myanmar by soldiers
marzia is just two days old she's a
child of the conflict a mother Zurich
attune gave birth to her daughter on the
road she fled to safety
Zhora tells me she's had no help no aid
or medical care for her baby this is
what starvation does it makes people
desperate
[Applause]
[Applause]
in the melee we see shu keen her
grandson does his best to protect the
frail old woman but all hell is breaking
loose
she can barely stand unaided 80 years
old and exhausted by her long difficult
journey across the border she struggles
to speak but manages to tell me she saw
her nephew killed and her home torched
keeping order is impossible these are
today's lucky ones clutching onto a
ticket a chit of paper that promises a
bowl of rice to stave off the hunger for
a short time at least more than 300,000
Rohingya are thought to have fled to
Bangladesh in the past few weeks that's
300,000 destitute people who need food
water shelter clothing
[Music]
we've been here for a number of days now
and we've yet to see any big
international aid organizations working
here on the ground
I'm not saying then over here we just
haven't seen any so these people are
totally dependent on local charities
either that or they'll just go hungry so
it's left up to volunteers like Mohammed
who have no experience of dealing with a
crisis of this so we request the NGOs
come here to and help them these people
have been reduced to begging fighting
for scraps
unbelievably their lives might worsen
tens of thousands of Rehavia
inside Myanmar is said to be on the move
making their way here more hungry mouths
to feed
and nobody to feed them Ashish Joshi Sky
News by locally by the wish